bonjour bonjour qui a empêché call of
quoi merci de répondre à nos questions
pourquoi avoir écrit cet article pour
dénoncer ces accusations américaines et
européennes il me semble que en occident
qu'il s'agisse de lait européens qu'il
s'agisse des états unis il y a une
volonté de cacher
l'impuissance totale de ces états nous
libéraux de ces états totalement
démantelée à gérer une crise sanitaire
qui n'est pas la première qui ne sera
pas la dernière et qui prend des
proportions absolument inacceptable dans
des pays développés et de rejeter cette
responsabilité sur la russie c'est à mon
sens si vous voulez une manière de
refuser de prendre ses responsabilités
et c'est absolument inacceptable
on sait qu'il ya un rapport du service
européen pour l'action extérieure il a
été publié le 16 mars ils reprochent à
moscou je cite d'aggraver la crise de
santé publique dans les pays occidentaux
en sapant la confiance du public dans
les systèmes de santé nationaux
quelles sont les preuves quelles sont
les sources sur lesquelles ce rapport se
base est ce que vous vous êtes procuré
cet article du coup si vous avez écrit
un article si vous avez écrit un article
vous êtes procuré ce rapport je voulais
dire alors selon les sources est publié
il y aurait en fait un simplement une
campagne de désinformation qui serait
ménée par sur les réseaux sociaux par
défaut compte du côté américain ou par
les médias dits comme russe qui vise
également alerté ce qu'ils lisent
spoutnik
il est quand même assez surprenant si
vous voulez de lire ce genre de choses
lorsque l'on sait très bien que
notamment ce qui manque à la france
la crise du service public hospitalier
et largement antérieure à la faire du
porno des russes
cela fait des années qu'il y à des
grèves des manifestations des médecins
qu'il y a des problèmes absolument
inacceptable dans les services
d'urgences qui a des problèmes au niveau
des infirmières du statut des
infirmières de leur façon de travailler
leurs possibilités de travail quasiment
surhumaine c'est un état de délitement
de l'état rhj qui fait suite à une mise
à sac totale des services publics ce qui
n'a strictement rien à voir avec la
communication les critiques peuvent être
faits de ça le fait de critiquer le
fonctionnement d'un service public d'un
état lorsque celui ci n'est plus apte à
assumer un fonctionnement normal des
institutions c'est faire oeuvre de
soutien à cette étape à ce qu'il faut
c'est son rôle sinon il n'a aucun sens
pour exister et les gens ont besoin de
ça et la manière avec l'ampleur que
prend cette crise qu'on avait russe dans
les pays occidentaux est absolument
inacceptable lorsque l'on compare avec
la façon de traiter et gérer en russie
on a l'impression que nous sommes dans
deux mondes totalement différents
d'un côté vous avez en russie un
gouvernement et un état qui fonctionne
et qui a dès le départ pris des mesures
systématiques de contrôle aux frontières
de suivi des personnes à risque de
confinement des personnes positives
c'est pas un régime comme on le voit en
france notamment qui met sa population
enfermée à domicile à ce qui est
incapable d'avoir des hôpitaux qui
fonctionnent comme comment réagissent
donc les autorités russes la presse
russe et la population russe par rapport
à la crise du crâne un virus par rapport
à la crise et par rapport aux
accusations surtout européennes et
américaines alors par rapport aux
accusations si vous voulez ça fait
doucement rire parce que ce n'est quand
même pas la russie qui a obligé macro
par exemple à ne faire aucun contrôle
dans les aéroports à l'arrivée ce n'est
pas la russie qui a obligé m'accroche à
liquider les stocks de masques
ce n'est pas la russie qui a obligé
macro et non plus à ne pas gérer la
question de la souveraineté médical de
la france donc cela fait quand même
quelques sourires mais c'est également
exaspérant parce que l'on aurait pu
penser que dans le cas d'une crise
sanitaire qui ont montré qu'ils
considéraient comme global qui considère
comme extrêmement importante l'on puisse
attendre n'ont pas ce genre de
mesquineries mais plutôt une solidarité
normal la russie elle fait fi de ces
critiques et propose immédiatement son
aide
dès qu'elle le peut notamment à l'italie
ils ont déclaré que la france n'a pas
proposé 100 n'a pas demandé l'aide mais
s'il est des demandes et la russie ce
mode si vous voulez de ces accusations
de basse politique il ya une
considération de l'homme une expliqué de
prise en compte de la valeur humaine que
manifestement l'on a perdu il me semble
en occident il serait temps se réveiller
un petit peu merci
karen bachelot love quoi d'avoir répondu
à nos questions